THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW, THERE WAS RAUCOUS APPLAUSE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
IT WASN'T FOR JOE'S HANDLING OF
COVID OR RUSSIA OR THE ECONOMY.
IT WAS BECAUSE THE REAL STAR WAS
BACK IN TOWN.
BARACK OBAMA.
>> PLEASE WELCOME PRESIDENT
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Laura: NOW, IF YOU THOUGHT
BIDEN LOOKED TENTATIVE AND
FEBRILE WHILE HE'S BEEN HIMSELF,
IT'S REALLY BAD WHEN HE'S ON THE
SAME STAGE WITH OBAMA.
BIDEN ALMOST APPEARED TO
DISAPPEAR IN THE BACKGROUND.
>> THANK YOU.
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN, VICE
PRESIDENT --
[LAUGHTER]
THAT WAS A JOKE.
I HEARD SOME CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE.
APPARENTLY SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
HAVE TO WEAR AVIATOR GLASSES
NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
THE NAVY METS HAVE BEEN REPLACED
BY A BASKIN ROBBINS AND THERE'S
A CAT RUNNING AROUND.
>> Laura: NOR AWHILE YOU NOR GOT
THAT BIDEN IS PRESIDENT.
AND HE'S 38% IN THE POLLS AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE SET TO GET
SHELLACKED IN THE MID-TERMS.
FOR A BRIEF MOMENT, IT WAS LIKE
OLD HOME WEEK.
>> JOE BIDEN AND I DID A LOT
TOGETHER.
HE'S DEDICATED HIS LEIF TO THE
PROPOSITION THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING WORRY ABOUT PUBLIC
SERVICE.
>> MY NAME IS JOE BIDEN.
I'M BARACK OBAMA'S VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: OBAMA IS JUST A
CONSTANT POLITICIAN.
HE DOES HAVE THE UNCANNY ABILITY
TO MAKE THE MOST MUNDANE THING
SOUND IMPORTANT AND TO SOUND
CONFIDENT EVEN WHEN THINGS ARE
FALLING APART.
BIDEN HAS THE OPPOSITE PROBLEM.
TODAY HE SEEMED EVEN LESS STEADY
AND SELF-ASSURED.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS WAS AN
EVENT TO CELEBRATE 12 YEARS OF
OBAMA CARE.
12.
IS THAT A SPECIAL ANNIVERSARY?
IT WAS AN EVENT TO TRY TO
RESUSCITATE JOE BIDEN.
CHOCK THAT UP AS ANOTHER SWING
AND A MISS.
THE PROBLEM WITH BIDEN, IT'S NOT
HIS COMS TEAMS, HIS P.R. OR NOT
THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE OBAMA STAR
POWER AND HE DOESN'T, THE
PROBLEM WITH BIDEN IS HIS
POLICIES.
NONE OF HIS SMOOTH TALK CHANGED
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
AMERICA CAN REALLY SEE CLEARLY
WHAT THE DEMOCRAT'S PRIORITIES
ARE.
NUMBER 1, OPEN BORDERS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN MY MIND
THAT BIDEN SEES IT AS HIS
MISSION TO ALLOW IN AS MANY
ILLEGALS AS POSSIBLE OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS.
MAYBE AS MANY AS 10 OR 15
MILLION WHEN ALL IS SAID AND
DONE.
SECOND PRIORITY, SEX TALK WITH
KIDS.
THE FLORIDA LEGISLATION IS THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THE BITE DEN WHITE HOUSE IS
ALIGNING ITSELF WITH THE MOST
RADICAL ELEMENTS ON THE ISSUE.
WHEN THEY'RE PRESSED ON IT, THEY
FALL BACK ON GENERALITIES.
>> AT WHAT AGE DOES THE WHITE
HOUSE THINK THAT STUDENTS SHOULD
BE TAUGHT ABOUT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY?
>> WE HAVE SPOKEN TO THE DON'T
SAY GAY BILL IN THE PAST.
WHAT WE THINK IS A REFLECTION OF
IS POLITICIANS IN FLORIDA
PROPAGATING HATEFUL POLICIES
THAT DO NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE
REAL ISSUES.
>> Laura: THAT WAS A SIMPLE
QUESTION THAT SHE COULDN'T OR
DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER.
IT'S JUST LIKE JUDGE JACKSON.
WHEN SHE PRETENDED SHE COULDN'T
DEFINE WHAT A WOMAN IS.
IN BOTH CASES, BOTH WOMEN KNEW
THE RIGHT ANSWER.
THEY KNEW IF THEY SAID THE
TRUTH, THEY WOULD BE DESTROYED
BY THE LEFT.
NO WONDER JEN PSAKI IS HEADING
FOR THE HILLS BEFORE THE
MID-TERMS.
I CANN'T BLAME HER:
.
NEXT, PROSECUTING TRUMP FOR
JANUARY 6.
SO BY 2024, THEY NEED TO KNOCK
HIM OUT OF CONTENTION.
>> HE TOOK AN OATH TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
HE FAILED TO DO THAT FOR MY
HOURS WHILE THE CAPITOL WAS
UNATTACK.
>> HE VIOLATED HIS OWN OATH.
>> IT WAS THE MOST DANGEROUS
MOMENT FOR OUR DEMOCRACY IN A
CENTURY.
>> THEY SEE THE NEW ATTORNEY
GENERAL AS THEIR NEW INSURANCE
POLICY.
ACCORDING TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," BIDEN SAID HE PRIVATELY
WANTED MR. GARLAND TO ACT LESS
LICK A JOB AND TAKE MORE AGAINST
OVER JANUARY 6.
DIDN'T BIDEN SAID HE WOULD NEVER
PRESSURE THE DOJ?
>> I TOLD YOU I WOULD NOT TELL
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHAT
POSITION TO TAKE.
I LEAVE THAT TO THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: JUST SO HAPPENED TO
LEAK OUT THAT HE WANTS GARLAND
TO BE A PROSECUTOR.
THEY ARE JUST OBSESSED WITH
TRUMP INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING
PROBLEMS LIKE INFLATION.
FOURTH PRIORITY, THE WAR ON
CARS.
IF YOU'RE NOT DRIVING A PLUG-IN,
YOU'LL BE PAYING THROUGH THE
NOSE FOREVER.
LET'S FACE IT'S.
HIGH GAS PRICES ARE NOT A
CONSEQUENCE OF BAD POLICY.
HIGH GAS PRICES ARE THE POLICY.
HE CANCELLED KEYSTONE, SUSPENDED
NEW FEDERAL OIL AND GAS LEASES,
RAISED FEES FOR FEDERAL DRILLING
ON LAND.
ORDERED ALL GOVERNMENT VEHICLES
TO BE ZERO EMISSION, ET CETERA.
GAS WAS $2.38 PER GALLON WHEN HE
TOOK OFFICE.
NOW IT'S $4.17 PER GALLON.
THAT'S A 75% INCREASE.
NUMBER 5, RACIAL RESENTMENT.
HAVE DEMOCRATS GIVEN UP ON
FIXING CITIES AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN THEY WRECKED BOTH AND NOW
THERE'S A MASS EXODUS OUT OF
BOTH.
CRIME IN UNDERPERFORMANCE WILL
DO THAT.
OF COURSE, CITY STRUGGLES TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN POLICE
BECAUSE OF COMMENTS LIKE THESE.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THERE IS
SYSTEMIC RACISM IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S NOT JUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENTS, IT'S ACROSS THE
BOARD.
IT'S IN HOUSING, IT'S IN
EDUCATION, IT'S IN EVERYTHING WE
DO.
IT'S REAL.
IT'S GENUINE.
IT'S SERIOUS.
>> Laura: NOW THESE ABSURD AND
INFLAMMATORY COMMENT ARE TYPICAL
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
BUT TOUTING THE DIVERSITY,
EQUITY AND INCLUSION RACKET ONLY
DIVIDES US FURTHER.
6th PRIORITY, DESTROYING WOMEN
SPORTS.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALL IN FOR THE
TRANS AGENDA, WHICH GOES FAR
BEYOND TOLERANCE TO DEMANDS THAT
YOU MUST ACCEPT AND CELEBRATE
THOSE CHOICES.
SO BY SUPPORTING BIOLOGICAL MEN
COMPETING ON GIRLS AND WOMEN'S
SPORTS TEAMS, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
A WAKENED THE MOB VOTE.
THE DAUGHTERS OF MOTHERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, THEY DIDN'T TRAIN
TO PLAY SOFTBALL JUST TO BE
DISPLACED BY SOME 6'2" GUY THAT
WHIFFED ON THE MEN'S BASEBALL
TEAM OR PRACTICED SWIMMING FOR
YEARS TO BE BUMMED BY A SPOT ON
THE ALL-AMERICAN TEAM BY SOMEONE
THAT SWAM WITH THE MEN TWO YEARS
AGO.
>> I CATCHED THEM GET OUT AND
CRY WITH THEIR COACHES AND
PARENTS BECAUSE OF THE EMOTIONAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL TURMOIL THAT
IS TAKING ON THESE WOMEN.
WE GREW UP TOLD THAT LIFE IS NOT
FAIR IN SPORT PROVIDES ONE OF
THE VERY FEW OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE HAVE RELIED UPON.
THAT IS BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM ALL OF A SUDDEN.
>> Laura: THE MOM VOTE.
TAKE IT TO THE BANK.
THIS ADDS UP FOR A PLATFORM OF
MISERY FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
AND TUESDAY'S BRIEF OBAMA BIDEN
REUNION WON'T DO ANYTHING.
IT ONLY REINFORCED WHAT WE
ALREADY KNOW.
THAT BIDEN DOESN'T KNOW WHAT ON
EARTH HE'S DOING OR AT TIMES
WHERE HE EVEN IS